tell me this is one of your simulations
right now all right
flush the Bombers get the subs in launch
mode we are at DEFCON 1 that was a scene
from the 1983 movie wargames a time when
the threat of a nuclear attack from the
Soviet Union was very real during the
Cold War the possibility of such an
attack on the nation's capital forced
the u.s. to devise a plan to keep its
government working in the event of a
catastrophe the Soviet Union has since
collapsed but the threat of a doomsday
is ever-present
just this week North Korea launched a
missile that some military experts
believe is capable of carrying a nuclear
warhead and striking Hawaii and Alaska
that system to keep the US government
working remains as do the remarkable
facilities in fact they're the subject
of the new book Raven Rock the story of
the US government secret plan to save
itself while the rest of us die it's
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS and we're joined by author
Garrett Graf Garrett good morning good
morning let's start right at the top
with the title Raven Rock what is it
so Raven Rock is one of the government's
three big bunkers it's in Waynesboro
Pennsylvania it's the alternate Pentagon
built in the 1940s and 1950s it is
literally a hollowed-out Mountain inside
Raven Rock mountain with freestanding
buildings hundreds of thousands of
square feet of office space three-story
buildings reservoirs Fire Department
police department medical facilities
dormitories cafeterias absolutely
everything you would need to live
underground for a month at a time
I can't even conceptualize exactly so
the Truman administration sort of had
this idea that if there's a nuclear
attack we need to do something to save
ourselves what was the dry run idea then
well so the arc of this has been you
know in the early years of these plans
in the 1940s 1950s during the eyes and
in Eisenhower years was you would be
able to evacuate the cities you would be
able to evacuate the US government out
into these bunkers out into relocation
facilities around wash
and then gradually as weapons got
stronger as we move to nuclear missiles
effectively it just became evacuation
helicopter evacuation planes sweeping a
small number of government officials out
into these mountain bunkers and the rest
of us would be left on our own but it's
not it's not just history in this book
there's actually fascinating present-day
accounts of what's still in place I mean
there's planes on runways that are
running 24 hours a day yeah so there's
this the set of planes the e4b
Nightwatch planes the president's
doomsday planes which are kept running
24 hours a day following the president
wherever he is when there he's in the
United States there's one on a runway at
Offutt Air Force Base in Omaha Nebraska
the president's in New York right now so
there's one of these planes following
him around Europe and he could run
nuclear war from the sky for three days
aboard one of these airborne command
posts so who gets in who gets into the
bunker or the plane and wherever with
the president not us other high-level
folks yeah don't get in well and this is
this was one of the funny stories I
uncovered in the book was that you end
up with these very secret plans and so
people may not even know who is that
their colleagues are part of these plans
and not them so when aaron sorkin was
doing the research for the west wing and
and the american president he was
talking to George Stephanopoulos and he
showed George Stephanopoulos is
evacuation pass which Aaron Sorkin
incorporated into an episode of The West
Wing
dee dee myers on set the White House
press secretary pulls Aaron Sorkin aside
and says you know this is crazy these
things don't really exist in Aaron
Sorkin's like wait you never knew you
were never going to be evacuated their
war not the way you want to find out
yeah they're really some great stories
in there also and obviously even into
9/11 sadly that's when we started seeing
some of these plans put into place the
book is raven rock and it's available
now wherever books are sold
author garrett Graf thank you so much my
pleasure